I know everything about him therefore I
know exactly the type of person I need
to be in order for him to think I'm good
enough for Andy no Jake you're fine just
flash him your baby Browns he'll love it
just be yourself be myself Charles I
have one day to win over Amy's dad how
long did it take before you guys started
liking Tom Boyd's
six months childres Doyle see Charles be
myself what kind of garbage advice is
that I hope you're not telling Nikolas
that crap Nico since it's been six
months the marshal is letting me write a
one-page letter to Jake which she will
read to him and then set on fire so
anything you guys want me to write you
have to tell Jake about my new scent
Nika wash that he's four years old he's
from Latvia
he calls me comrade and I love him so
much we'll do Roza anything you want to
tell Jake yeah that's what I said
you want me to write that you nodded
slightly well know what it means okay
everyone let's just try to bring things
we actually need for the mission really
then what is this oh it's a book of
4,000 essential photos of me collage for
me to show Jake all right bad news I'll
talk to captain stantly again he still
won't give us permission to go to
Florida I even brought out the big gun
left right left right both both both I
still can't let you go to Florida though
he feels like a [ __ ] if he isn't taking
his medicine you could mix it in with
his food sorry you can deal with your
sick dog later Boyle well actually that
was about my son ecolodge he's cut
allergies I think we may have to go with
the nasal douche nasal douche cool Jake
come on in me claps look who it is
remember Jake Peralta from the stories
yeah we talked about you at bedtime
look at my seaming he loves trucks oh
cool buddy hey listen I know you're with
your kid but I checked the file and her
perps last known address is like two
blocks from here
really we got to go take him down yes
there's the Charles I know tonight Dave
Smith goes down tonight no Charles we
gotta go now
you saw this guy's rap sheet he was
arrested for attempted for tickling
giggling attempted tickling right
tickling look Charles this guy's a real
doodyhead
all right he tickled once he made tickle
again he might be tickling as we speak
we could be dealing with a serial
tickler I really want to go Jake but I'm
here alone with knee Kailash Genevieve
doesn't get back for three hours so
let's just take it with us now that's
crazy
or is it just crazy enough to work
just crazy ah man that stinks you gotta
watch him it's really messing everything
up I mean that came out wrong I love
that you have a son it's not messing
everything up
just messing up our ability to solve the
case and have fun yeah you know what I
mean
I'm a nice guy I'm in the right I'll
just go myself find a collage Nikola
Papa's here there's a place for my
clothes oh honey she's okay I'm here
monsters aren't real my little pierogi
but I saw it was big and hairy you just
had a nightmare buddy no it was real
sure it felt that way but I I'm gonna
open this closet and I'm gonna show you
that there's nothing in there don't do
that blah blah see nothing hey Chuck its
pimento ah the boils are here good
tidings
Genevieve hello you're looking sexy as a
minx I was gonna say festive due to the
scarf the bra underneath is insane it is
okay parenthood has not changed you too
hey there Nikolai's my man how you doing
we make daddy Lobby Christmas cookies
what what you bet I do
the potato really brings out the vinegar
neither of those are cookie things I'm
gonna put that back so you excited for
Christmas bud yeah I'm so excited this
is Nicholas first Christmas because the
orphanage kept cancelling it once it was
blizzards once it was fires and once it
was Andy that's right famine huh pabu
promised me the best present ever
caps-lock yeah I can figure whoa captain
Latvia
what's his superpower can he talk to
moose no opossums worse it's a very
difficult toy to get in America so I was
worried when Charles told Nikolaas he
would get him one I said keep it a
surprise so you don't build up his
expectations but Charles said no way I
want to build expectation oh you all
will remember the conversation Oh
work time for daddy I'll see you guys
later okay I love you guys so much love
you all right all right Christmas is
gonna be amazing
Christmas is gonna suck I don't have the
present what but you promised a collage
I ordered it a month ago from a Latvia
Toy Story and it still hasn't arrived
yet the shipping company is giving me
the runaround all right so just get him
a different present like a jet ski or a
hammer I don't know what kids are into
shouldn't be
and I worked so hard to get Nikolai
should trust us when we brought him home
that's gonna be destroyed the way dry
rot destroyed his orphanage trust me
it's gonna be fine
really you said that about die hard 5
Jake oh it's not gonna be fine
hey what's up I can't work the case
tonight new collages allergies are
acting up and now the dog seems to be
allergic to him is this whole thing did
you find Smith no he actually got away
sorry man that's all right it's the day
chefs problem now whatever happened to
working at old stud honestly lohank kind
of talked some sense into me lohank yeah
it was so gross but I want to apologize
for what well I kept talking about how I
wanted everything to go back to normal
but if that actually happened
this little guy wouldn't be here or is
he big I don't know what size kids are
supposed to be or anything about kids
really I think maybe that's part of the
problem it doesn't matter I got a
present for Annie collage thanks Jake
come on give it to me Niko hey oh man oh
you want to know something cool a truck
just like this almost killed me today
hmm kiss me I almost kissed me anyway
let's get some trash in this thing I'm
all right yeah I am silly oh my god this
is a dream come true
I gotta get my phone I gotta film this
oh but then I'll miss it no but I want
it forever
oh but I should stay in the moment don't
forget oh my god nightmares Smith sounds
like a real piece of crap you said it
now we just got to pull his files from
Records yeah then we bust him and we'll
be done with plenty of time before an
eco-lodge makes up Mikolaj hmm Nicholas
yeah I said Nikolas Nikolas even close
Nikolas Nikola almost Nikolas Nikolas I
feel like I'm saying you know what it
doesn't matter hit me with the music
you